(dramatic music)
- Chemistry explains literally everything
that is happening around you.
The dry ice is taking the
thermal energy from the water.
Unfortunately I instantaneously
get judged on my appearance.
That is very frustrating for me.
So, I'm gonna pick up my hot water.
I'm gonna come over here
and I’m gonna throw it
right into my bucket, okay?
It means I have to work harder,
but at the end it is so,
so incredibly worth it.
And one.
(banging)
(children scream and cheer)
(dramatic music)
My name is Dr. Kate Biberdorf,
and I am a lecturer at the
University of Texas at Austin.
I'm trying to break the stigma
of what a stereotypical
scientist looks like,
so my thing is I am not wearing a bow tie,
I'm not wearing suspenders,
I don't have some frumpy cardigan on,
I'm just some regular girl
who likes to play with fire
and I also really like designer shoes
and that's okay.
As the alginate hits the calcium chloride,
the alginate would prefer
to be with the two-plus charge calcium
instead of the one-plus charge sodium
and what happens
is we form gummy worms.
It doesn't matter what you look like,
any human can be a scientist.
I definitely try to use
energy and excitement.
I love this one.
I do my best to try to reach students
that might be intimidated by science.
I use anything that will make
the 483 students sit up straight
and actually listen to the
words coming out of your mouth.
(banging)
As soon as I've exploded
something in their face,
I have their attention for just 60 seconds
and I can do whatever I
can to shove that knowledge
right into their brains.
Ah, yay.
Okay, so what we're gonna do today
is learn some chemistry.
We're going to do three
different hands-on experiments.
I find chemistry to be an
incredibly challenging topic.
Pour your water, pour your water.
Beautiful, now keep
watching, keep watching.
I'm so sick of the
stereotypical female scientist
and we can do things other
than biology, by the way.
Chemistry, physics,
engineering, we can do it.
Look at what you made.
The fact that I've been able to master it
but then use science to
start the conversation
but then physically stand
there and break that image.
It's the most rewarding thing
I could ever do ever.